okay all right here we go let's get this
right who's taking pictures ah how do
you get your camera in anyway cameras
your nose I use the I usually cue the
skies and your flashlights off and look
at each other in the eye
oh my god holy crap hello everybody my
name is markiplier and welcome to a
scary gmod map with wade Bob and Jack Oh
top of the morning to you laddies my
name is jacksepticeye and i'm playing
gmod horror would mark Bob and weed hey
guys welcome to gmod horror with Jack
mark and Bob a bobble heads my scrim
here and welcome to a gmod horror map
featuring the cast of five nights at
Freddy's oh it's the creepiest thing
that's ever happened oh my gosh I can
have fists as a weapon what iswhat do I
look like someone shine a light on me
you're just pointing I want the camera
how'd you get the camera out it's under
uh weapons under other oh that's right
okay okay okay so now we all have a
camera so we can document this horrible
experience and give everyone seizures
who's watching maybe listen I don't have
a camera I'm not getting check it out oh
my god oh please no flash warning
Oh No the flashes what is that nothing
are we ready to actually get started on
this man yes if I really get scared okay
so who's gonna lead us in this endeavor
should have money and she can come first
yeah they do most of the time is Bonnie
so Bob you're leading us yeah
put away that slam yeah no slams here
yeah noticing our Jam I welcome to the
slams I Bob's creeped me out Bob um Oh
Bob disconnected Oh Oh God thought it
was actually Bonnie for a minute it was
terrifying okay okay
Bob you're leading us decided no no no
yeah maybe you kill Bonnie hope I get my
trusty I'll get my trusty crowbar out
and let's do it good I'm ready
and funnily enough it's in alphabetical
order yes how are you guys dressed
passing loitering we're no loitering
yeah I don't think this is gonna open
Bob you've led us astray
this guy's hold on something huh what
give it to me
wait who's doing what Jack where are you
I mean run into rooms I got something Oh
what you got well I'm just I'm just
pressing all this box uh he was holding
it yeah fun Bob in there we got this
very important thing that he's holding
what is that a piece of a puzzle
let me see put it in the picture trust
no I'm Freddy I'm the leader gimme gimme
gimme gimme gimme
hey I I don't know the picture that we
got uh oh this is hard to walk with I'll
be the center here so that we can come
back I'm good why no put it up here put
it up here where I uh
good cuz your eyes are creepy I know
your oh there we go
oh go find pieces yeah we got our side
pieces everybody split up all right it's
a good idea how did you pick them up II
I don't know do we got it I just wasn't
on it hmm
hi Freddy that's creepy mmm all right
are you puzzle pieces the first couple
rooms know that we miss ya Bob you left
her god I can see your eyes from a long
way Bob I just complimented you so the
gun away
ah these things are impossible to walk
with walk back oh I wanted your piece
you recall what's with the hold oh uh
why did you start playing some jazz that
was a creepy guy but where did my piece
go I got it I got it uh
you don't know who's over here I really
don't want to cross the threshold of
SLAM wait is don't you [ __ ] dare
don't you dare oh that's what you get
for killing Freddy Freddy yes my man
yeah me and Bonnie I got your back
Freddie thanks bon bon bon hands call me
bonbon alright bonbon [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
Foxy's the only one I'm your little
bonbon yeah I hate this game
hey you guys I'm going home yeah yeah
damn oh why not oh there's an hour every
single overhead ouch I can see in the
doorway where truce truce truce truce
truce truce truce oh here oh oh then
vent vent we need to go in the venn
Vince will be doing kitsch
where's the vent I gotcha where is it
dad back it out of the way we'd stop
trying to kill everybody
try pressing the use button on it oh
that didn't stop it hang on all right
let me think about this
mmm-hmm place all this all work just let
me keep doing this try open it oh I have
an idea
Oh bud hey mark watch I know how to find
it oh no Bob no no Bob that's cheating
we're cheating no I'm not
we're not yeah I got this guy's is long
before his MLG peacefinder right now I
found like five so yeah I haven't found
any good they were like the corpses of
my friends but yeah hey guys I found
more map and somehow this door became
open and it was an accident
Wow darn it Bob oh my god did it
everybody hey we solved the puzzle
it ran out of power and it opened okay
yeah no it's done and it happened on its
own what's going on I like this I like
this butters I'm sorry I'm in here
locked boxes boxes didn't do the bad
know some patterns are bad we're the
baddest sons of [ __ ] in this game
well that fazbear's cruise I don't think
this map is working properly since we
cheated to get down choppers no get your
crowbar back out way do you hold it with
your with your hook oh do I
there's just a Kovar sitting on your
hook hey foxy what you gonna do oh good
oh wow who did that
Oh Bob wait you just call Sully only
you're saying I know oh my god it killed
me oh sorry oh okay okay that's good
wait wait can't seem to put you guys
there um somebody broke at the door yes
we know this jack that's how we got down
to the basement
the door there before you know what I'm
I'm gonna try and find a breakthrough in
the basement here I'm gonna go in this
back room I think there I think there's
something back here yeah there's gonna
be I can't just be holy why why why is
this the thing in the back room
nothing Bob knows how to gmod getting a
lot of slams hey oh you guys are picking
him up no don't pick him up what okay Oh
God okay I can't throw that's not that's
not good I can't throw these very
quickly just let's take it out ah you
guys suck you're ruining all my stuff
I'm trying to do something here okay
okay well all right then what we do that
do is I'm not spawning any weapons Yeah
right
whoop oh hi jack that's a claim the
scares in this key on that terrified me
say we shoot for seven plus two point
one zero what that times a thousand
you're the mathematician of this group
it's seven two four nine times a
thousand Bo seven two four nine zero
zero zero correct that's one in 10x
Matt's Verburg below Evan Boop - OH
nine zero zero zero
Wow when you have two times a thousand
then add two because of the order of
operations or operations I thought that
I can't believe it worked anyway despite
all that that's where the vent went I
have a key whoa whoa whoa what's that
sound I don't know my tech knows uh okay
then Oh done lock the lock on the main
door
we're winning yeah we're winning
legitimately all the weights are yeah
yeah that's okay okay
Oh No okay there we go calm down there
bunny hey worki yeah anything wait he I
told you guys we broke the map how did
way to break the map did it not work for
you guys that work for me wait no you're
right perpetual locks yes well maybe
that was the key to this door
cuz there's another door that's locked
here if the key jack maybe worse what is
your like back and forth a whole bottle
I don't know where we are anymore
I don't either well I think we're went
out I think we hang look at this we wait
no no no I'm gonna grab the key I'm
gonna see if this actually does work
meditate away here we go
these parties is Freddie's ice rink
we're the goddamn key go wait where's
the key I thought it goes right here I
picked it up and it went away
where is over here I'm holding it okay
go bring it with me baby you dropped it
we okay anyway bring it or two hi Bobby
wait give it dear okay hahaha it won't
go through the gunman barrier yeah you
should go into third-person elephant oh
yeah broke at this game so no egos
where's the keepers of you okay mf5
maybe a rough four cubs are eventually I
got it I got it like it neither Oh God
ice skating
oh shut that okay we have not done
okay all right well yeah there's a lot
of like overly attached girlfriend has
her own channel now that doesn't really
know Lena I can never remember there
actually yeah Lena has one I ran into
her when I was doing a fine brother sing
she's really cool but I didn't get a
chance to talk with her this is like all
these internet memes that you see and
people yeah what was that
oh well I uh um what I think we need to
shoot this electric box and then it'll
just open you're right
ed open it works good job whoa oh it
opened on a delay for us so you know
yeah that was uh it was yours early to
cool off to go okay alright what Oh God
oh sorry
so we're in the party room huh this was
that was mainly copyright beer I got
here
died you're gonna let him go here he's
not he's not safe mister shape gently
there we go oh yeah perfect landing oh
well are you ready